what was that song by Tupac everywhere I
go I see the same same but no matter
what was that bigger I see it uh now I
was that was uh that was popped every
other video no matter where I go yeah
I'm pretty sure I see the same and Luda
did One two talking about uh Ludacris
did when it's called yeah
but anyway here we go another time yeah
another time or or when is it all about
the men are men just too weak today was
my first question and I'm saying real
quick and you can just tell me what you
think about it because it seems to me
that women are easier today we're
talking about just just having sex just
smashing it's easier today than it was
20 years ago I mean I'll be it's
definitely easier today yeah I'll be 52
next week and I went out just you know
just sometimes I go I just I want to see
what these guys are talking about right
I go out like can you curse on this I'm
like what the what the f bomb yeah I'm
like what the F-bomb it's all these
dudes what's going on is this it's
simple almost so uh and then it was like
um
why is it and these are three things
just real quick in succession the third
one is like why do these guys refuse
let's do one at a time okay one at a
time weaker today yes absolutely they're
100 weaker than what they were 25 years
ago when I was when I was in elementary
school you could use the r word you
could walk up to your friend right in
front of the teacher be like yo what's
up r word right and they and nothing
would happen you can't even say that
today
okay they they have gender neutral
bathrooms in elementary school something
we never had before if somebody was
acting outside of the conventional
traditional conservative Norms they
would be made fun of you can't do that
today right so I think bullying
probably is is what kept a lot of
culture and Society in line back in
those days and the removal of bullying
from the schoolyard or
like schooling and and society and
culture trying to equalize a playing
field and make everybody equal and make
everybody the same they want you all
[ __ ] vanilla you're not allowed to be
different you're not allowed to have you
know like different colors different
emotions different whatever like you
can't wear certain things anymore right
it's like now they want you all to be
the same stand on your [ __ ] dots take
your you know take your Jabs follow the
rules you know like they've been trying
to get us to do the last couple years so
when you do that to men you know you
wean out the dangerous risk-taking
testosterone-fueled boy that turns into
a man right when I was a kid in school
like you know the playgrounds freeze
here in the wintertime obviously in
Toronto you'd see a puddle it would
freeze overnight it'd be like awesome
and you take a run and you slide across
see how fast you can go and you you and
your friends would keep doing that and
keep doing that to see who would fly the
farther you can't do that in school
yards today teachers come up to you and
they say don't do that and they put a
[ __ ] coat on it and they say you're
not allowed to do that why because it's
too dangerous because because one kid
wiped out and got a [ __ ] scrape and
then the parent threatened this you know
sue the school so now there's a [ __ ]
Co in there because we have to pussify
everything it's the same thing with cars
you know if you look at cars 20 30 years
ago the design language you know the
design architecture they were very
different sports cars were prominent
they were very masculine now somebody
sent me this meme the other day I shared
it on Twitter and it was a picture of
every single SUV that every car
manufacturer makes all the way from
Mercedes down to Kia in white in the
exact same paint Scheme and they all
look nearly identical they're [ __ ]
vanilla boxes they're boring as [ __ ]
fortunately they still make some
supercars but you have to make money to
go and buy those right but the vast like
they want you all conforming to the same
color the same style they want you
pussified so that's the direction that
culture and Society is taking us which
is why we have softer weaker men now we
also have a lot of men today that have
been raised in single mother households
which wasn't as prominent 20 30 years
ago all all of my friends in school you
go hang out with them you go to their
parents house their parents were there
there was almost no divorce households
there was almost no single mothers
raising kids and I was in a middle class
sort of neighborhood right but today
most kids are raised in a single parent
household and yeah when they say single
parent what that means a single mom
because women still get 80 of the
custody orders or single moms that are
having children at a wedlock being
knocked up by Chad or Tyrone doesn't
matter you know who it is but she's just
carrying the seat of the alpha pops them
out and then she goes on a dating site
sometimes pregnant looking for the next
[ __ ] you know beta male to
take care of her problems that you know
she created for herself so guys are weak
which is why you see the man of swamp
today as big as it is today which is why
you see you know these um podcast shows
with all the gals sitting at the table
which is why you see gals sitting at a
table coming in the man of swamp getting
the attention resources of men because
there's a lot of weak like these guys
are simping there is no other way to put
it other than if you're sitting there
watching one of these gals on YouTube
trying to tell you how to be a man
you're simping like you look at the
comments and they're like they're
clearly simping right so is that a
problem yeah but the good news is guys
it's very easy to stand out from that
[ __ ] crowd
yes you know why it's easier to smash
right that's why it's easier to get
women 70 of the population doesn't have
a healthy BMI
they just don't they're overweight so
the first thing is just don't be fat
like don't be overweight and you'll
stand out from the vast majority of the
crowd okay good now that you got that
get some style cool now that you got
that go to the gym uh pick up a fighting
sport you know become competent in that
sense cool now you got some money make
more money got more money become more
captivating do fun [ __ ] take fun trips
invite gals and you know in your world
to do so it's really easy to get women
when you're when you've got all the you
know the you know the six sixes you sort
of checked out just a couple of them
really I mean I I tell a lot of these
guys I'm like bro just be confident man
go in there you know they're worried
about designer clothes well that's what
the P well that's what the Pua say right
like the puas are just like just make
the approach be you know be confident
and you'll and you'll get the the date
you'll get the you know the lay whatever
and it's like that works for some guys
and maybe they do get what they're
looking for that one time but if your
success ratios like you know you're
making 50 approaches and you're getting
one number and maybe like I don't know
10 or 20 of the time that turns into a
date or maybe a intimacy sort of segment
is she gonna stick around if you have
roommates and you play video games and
you're a stoner and you're 31 working at
Walmart
probably not nah she's done if you have
to have the rest you're absolutely right
bro and that's so okay and then so that
leads to women being easier because it's
not much they're all competing for the
same dudes like you said like here in
America where it's like yeah 75 of
Americans are either overweight or obese
you know what I mean so 25 you're there
the last one was um why is it that men
refuse to accept these new ground rules
I talked to these guys that's to the
point where I'm I'm sick of talking to
somebody because it's easier to complain
than it is to do the work
it's easier to be a little [ __ ] and
complain about the card that you've been
dealt and a lot of guys make up reasons
why they're upset they're upset because
they don't have hair they they're they
have the wrong skin color they're not
tall enough there's bone structure like
there's legitimate so this is one of the
problems with the mantle swap is there's
legitimate channels that prey on
persuadable guys to adopt the losers
quitters mindset which is which is good
for guys doing the work okay because it
because then there's less competition
out there but they don't need to accept
that you don't need to accept failure I
know lots of short guys that get plenty
of ladies I know lots of guys with many
different colored skin that do fine with
ladies some have more of a struggle
depending on where they live in the
demographics but they can still kind of
navigate through it it's like you do the
best that you can you're losing your
hair shave your [ __ ] head
you can grow a nice beard grow a nice
beard and trim it out right like have a
look you know don't be fat like stay fit
hi right look good it's it's not that
difficult you know you just sort of max
out but that's but that's a large and
growing demographic right like that's
like that's a problem you almost stay in
the fight brother I mean I'm I'm gonna
take up uh you're a mantle I'm gonna
start counting Mano swamp as well I've
been trying to be nice but being nice
isn't working I'm gonna have to keep the
hardcore like that Airborne [ __ ] behind
me and last thing before I go my cousin
you talk about women being harder and
stuff like that my cousin she's well to
do very beautiful she's looking for a
new car I'm going with her she she's
hunting for a a BMW m850 competition we
get into the car and we start it up and
I'm like no get out get out of this car
you can't have this you want to talk
about a machine bro I I think it would
have kept up with you in that material I
think it's uh 600 and
it came stock 620 horsepower I think 615
or something like that yeah yeah that's
a lot of cars that's not a girl's car oh
man she went she got an m850 but I was
able to talk about it yeah I was able to
talk her out of it yeah it's still a lot
of car I mean
it's a lot of questions you got a great
deal I mean right now the bottom fell
out so she was able to get you know her
price and everything but but here it is
this is a woman getting this vehicle how
old is she
uh she won't want me to tell her but she
don't know 840s
uh she is she's very well off she's in
telecommunications she's very well off
she's doing it she is definitely into
six figures she's probably making 200
plus well well yeah well north of six
figures yeah there's lots of there's
lots of really successful you know 40
year old women they got degrees in their
walls framed in Mahogany she married she
have kids
nah she's doing you know chasing
Excellence then right yes she's been
chasing Excellence she's one of the
candidates for Kevin Samuels I don't
understand why I can't get a high value
man
it's more she's become the man she wants
possibly one of those kind of things
well that's what a lot of women do right
they you know they they they set this
image for themselves on what attraction
is
and then they completely forget that
women are Beauty objects and that
if there's an older guy that's you know
45 years old and he's got his money
sorted out he has a choice between a
boss babe making a quarter million
dollars a year driving a BMW 850i nice
car you know by the way probably has her
life together you know you said she's
beautiful so I trust you that's great
but if there's a 28 year old
that's hotter and he's got his money
sorted out he's he's probably gonna go
for the younger one like why wouldn't he
yeah you can't compete against your
young I tell it to people it's a tough
market for the gals right it's very
difficult like look as fine as you are
as much as you've done you can't compete
with your 28 year old self yeah they'll
get 18 year old stuff you can't do it
yeah like a 45 year old woman that's got
her [ __ ] together will get a 55 60 year
old guy
right but even those guys are fewer and
far between right because as you get
older guys start to fall apart there's
very few I don't know that many In-Shape
guys that are like 55 60.
it's not a lot of us chubby I'm like
skinny fat I gotta keep forcing myself
to get up and do the push-ups and go
into the gym keep putting in the Reps
man like you know for me to look like
this dude I fight two times a week I
have a trainer twice a week I throw in
an extra workout during the week I do a
lot of walking right diet diet two you
know my diet styled in you know my
girl's an excellent [ __ ] culinary
like she like she knows how to push it
together she's in shape too so it's like
I don't have to worry about that part of
my life right
this is not easy to accomplish like
trust me this is almost like a full-time
job for me to do this [ __ ] okay the
older we get it gets that way bro and uh
therapeutic testosterone the peptides
the vitamins the supplements all the
[ __ ] all that good [ __ ] man yo and I
appreciate the talk man I grew up on the
other side of that you're I'm like the
polar opposite of the way you came up
but here's the thing it doesn't matter
and I tell you all these dudes you know
[ __ ] excuses man y'all got to get out
there and get after it man you got to
get in the trenches and these dudes are
afraid to engage man Point Blank period
last question I want to ask you real
talk
there are a lot of people coming to the
window Squad just to just basically to
rip these guys off just like the women
on the other side are ripped them off
you know I mean there are guys out there
who are really trying to help these
dudes out
um do you think it's wrong to set a
business model in the man of swamp right
now just morally speaking
everybody's got something to sell right
I mean I look I was already financially
successful before I started up YouTube
uh my business still runs you know the
like the main business that I set up 20
years ago now it's going to be 20 years
old in February of uh 2023. thanks
very uncommon feat um you know if you
look at the stats but anyway
um
yeah I just started doing videos for fun
because I wanted to do car videos with
entrepreneurs and people were asking me
about life problems uh you know like
talk about the kind of women to avoid
dating started talking about that sort
of [ __ ] then sort of unpack my own
wounds and made them my work on the
channel
I did that for quite a while I mean now
you'll go to YouTube and you'll have
like a brand new channel the guy's like
you know buy my new course on become a
pickup artist or sign up for my new how
to run a harem of 20 [ __ ] you know
sort of thing and it's like
okay well there's that you know like you
know one side of the scale you got the
girls looking for the attention and the
money and the super chats and all that
the other side of the scale you got the
guys like I'll you know like I'll teach
you how to bed you know 1 000 women like
I did or I'll teach you how to
um run a harem of 20 checks and like the
customers that they're that they're
selling these courses to they're the
same guys that you're dealing with you
know they're socially awkward you know
they're overweight they don't make a lot
of money they're insignificant they
don't have a captivating life like you
fix all of those things like once you
once you understand what women are
attracting like women what women really
respond to you don't need to play games
you don't need to memorize lines you
don't need to buy courses it's like
they're kind of easy like like it's not
that difficult just stay away from the
Psychopaths stay away from the ones with
the red flags like the last dude that
you know has a false grape allegation
thing like you know you see she's got
five red flags I don't I don't care I
don't care how big her tits are or how
good she looks or whatever it is that's
like drawing you in right like there'll
be another one there's another bus that
comes along like just pass let her
become somebody other somebody else's
problem but it's only when you're
thirsty
and it's only when you know you chase
women too much that's why when I was
talking earlier there's two kinds of
guys that you can't trust right guys
that are always chasing girls to try to
get laid and there's always the other
guys that just can't get laid because
they'll throw you under the bus for
anything right so every single time when
that becomes an obsession and you make
it your life that's when I see it as a
problem and it's like okay dude like
what color is your McLaren you know and
Andrew Tates word sort of thing like why
aren't you [ __ ] like chasing other
things in life other than just [ __ ]
right and I quote you all the time man
Chase Excellence the one of the things I
tell these guys I'm like look bro you
know I mean you gotta chase Excellence
women or that's a byproduct women are a
byproduct of the byproduct of you doing
the work and they love that you it
doesn't matter they're not the goal they
are the accessory and if they're the
goal they're gonna run your pockets bro
like again I came up through the streets
man like I tell these guys when it comes
to women's like money all money ain't
good money and you know what I'm talking
about I don't I can't I don't know how
many times you get hit up by people who
want to give you money just so you can
talk to them or go into their platform
and I know you say no all money ain't
good money all women and good women you
see like you said if she's hot or
whatever there's another one right
around the corner and I'll leave you
with this
for these young guys I'm a 52 year old
man I can still get out there and run my
game I had a woman who woke up the next
morning and she said um you know that
game you use that line you used on me
was real corny and she and she paused
for a moment and she said
as I tell you this in my bed the next
morning I'm like exactly you feel for
the Coney game baby now I'll see you
tomorrow all right man
I'll see you later okay peace thanks bud
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out